well thank you very much so our
presentation is a little different at
least my piece of it because we focused
a little more a little bit more on the
strategy behind what it is that we're
doing Brad is then going to tell you a
lot more about how this works in
practice so you know Brad and I have
been working on a piece of this together
and it's exciting to have him here so
you can walk you through this and tell
you exactly what's happening in the
program itself in a starting point for
us is that technology is really the
second step we're starting with the
strategy of our school what it is that
we're trying to accomplish globally and
we got to the point we realize that
technology could play an incredibly
useful role in helping us accomplish
that so allow me to sort of give you a
very quick context for this
experimentation with online formats our
mission is to educate leaders for
business and society we have formulated
three strategic aspirations for our team
under our Dean Ted Snyder the second one
is the one that I really want to draw
your attention to which is to become the
most distinctively global US business
school US business schools are not very
global even the ones who claim to be
global tend to only have about thirty
percent or so international students
they might do a joint Executive MBA
part-time program or they might have
another sort of initiative some student
exchanges but for the most part the
majority of their students are not
really impacted by any kind of
international collaborations that's a
real challenge of course because in
business as well as in so many other
fields people really have to be prepared
for a much more global environment they
have to understand that customers are
different in different places their
regulations are different in different
places cultures are different in
different places and how do you do that
when your model essentially is to bring
people to one place and keep them there
for two years we've put together and you
may have heard about this over the last
two years something pretty exciting that
we call the global network for Advanced
Management it's a network of now 25 top
business schools from around the world
it's the only network of its kinds most
of our peer schools might have a couple
of exchange part
they might have one strong partner for a
joint degree but nobody has a network of
this kind and we have some of the
leading business schools from Europe
insead I business school I indeed the
London School of Economics and from Asia
National University of Singapore Hong
Kong University of Science and
Technology fudan university but what is
really exciting about the network is we
have the top business school from Turkey
in the top business school from South
Africa on the top is in school from
Ghana and the Philippines and Costa Rica
and Chile so it's a really really broad
and diverse group of schools and their
number of things that we do together we
bring our students together for
week-long interactions in different
parts of the world about 500 students in
total across the network will be
participating in something we call
global network weeks we're working
together on case studies we're working
to connect faculty and one of the things
that we've started to do is to connect
our students via small online courses
now and we call these courses global
network courses when we just quickly
explain at a high level the concept so
everybody who participates in one of
these courses is an enrolled MBA student
at one of the global network schools
they do this in the context of their
degree programs we have had now while
we're at three we're about to launch the
fourth of these golden network courses
brad is teaching the third so he'll tell
you a little bit more about this in just
a minute but these are faculty led
courses fairly small groups anywhere
between 20 and 60 students who are drawn
from these different campuses and
they're doing this course in the context
of their programs as yet another
elective course there's a lot of focus
on global issues among the topics we
wouldn't be doing this to teach
introductory accounting it's supposed to
be focused on global topics there's a
lot of emphasis on students doing group
work in the context of these courses
because one of the things that they can
learn through these courses is to
collaborate virtually across time zones
across language barriers and so on the
course is always offered by one global
network school and that school is
responsible for the evaluation for
credits and that's
sort of thing and no cash changes hands
of a student from London School of
Economics wants to take a course offered
by Brad we're not charging them for that
the reason why we're not charging them
is because in the future we're hoping
that a faculty member at the London
School of Economics will be offering a
course that some of our students might
be joining so the idea here is really
one around diffuse reciprocity and have
a picture there may have wondered who's
the person there this is David Ricardo
and so the whole idea here is this is
really influenced by this notion of
comparative advantage there are a couple
of things that were really good at there
are a couple of things that you're good
at we're actually better off if we all
offer something that were particularly
good at and everybody gets to join in
the benefits of of that collaboration
the first two courses were in the fall
of 2013 you see on the right hand side
our Dean together with two faculty
colleagues Fiona Scott Morton and Pierre
cream you they taught a course for 29
students on competition policy and
during the same semester one of my
colleagues k so dear taught a course to
17 students when three schools about
mobile banking opportunities in both of
these courses there was this combination
of lectures that were streamed playa
Adobe Connect and a lot of group work
and presentations back later on we were
very efficient in our first iteration of
this we didn't even bother Lucas and his
team we actually borrowed in quotation
marks the online learning platform of
one of our global network schools and
the Ricardian sense this semester we're
using canvas and that is a step up but
you know this was not particularly
expensive to do because there's a lot of
borrowing involved these are the two
courses that are being offered right now
one is natural capital risks and
opportunities and global resource
systems and that's Brad scores and we'll
talk about it in just a minute and we're
excited that in a few weeks we're
kicking off the first course in this
series offered by a non Yale faculty
member a professor at the Technion in
Israel who's going to teach a course on
new product development with about seven
or eight yell students and 25 students
from other school
there is strong interest among our
network seven schools including us have
already expressed interest in offering a
call course like this in the fall and
we're hoping that in the medium term we
end up in a position where maybe a dozen
or so of our 25 schools are offering one
or two of these courses a year and you
can see how that might be an interesting
pool of electus for our students before
I turn it over to Brad let me just draw
some clear distinctions between what
we're doing here and what gets so many
of the headlines our Dean is calling
these snacks small Network online
courses we've given them a lot of flack
for the abbreviation it has survived all
of the ridicule the point of it is you
know people have this this sort of
instinct to think that technology means
massive and you can use technology as I
think the nursing school example shows
to craft you know very very intimate
interactions among students sometimes
even more intimate than what you would
get in a physical classroom and that's
really what we're trying to do here with
these snarks so the students come from
existing academic programs they're pre
qualified as opposed to just you know
anybody unscreened to signs up for a
MOOC there's a lot more interaction
happening among these students and among
these schools than just that course
because it takes place in the context of
a degree program and students actually
get credit for it you know there was an
expectation that people actually finish
that course as supposed to you know the
ninety-five percent of a dropout rate
that you see in some moves it's much
more about the students and
collaboration among them facilitated by
a faculty member then the star faculty
member is very often to draw off a move
and of course you know we're really
focused on developing skills and
capabilities in addition to imparting
knowledge MOOCs have a place no doubt
this is something very very different
and just because both of them use
technology we shouldn't be confusing
them let me turn it over to Brad who can
tell you a little bit more about his
course and then I think we jointly can
answer questions about this initiative
see where because it's just a browser so
it's just the browser yeah I'm the
browser Davis mm-hmm I was talking about
school management interest here I also
share a faculty position of the school
of Forestry and environmental studies
and when we saw the creation of the
global network for advanced management
we said wow what a wonderful opportunity
to connect business and environment
around the world around sustainability
issues and that's how we really
structured the course here on managing
risks and opportunities across global
resource systems the students that are
involved and we think they're 65 signed
up 45 to 48 seem active so I'm not quite
sure how many students to say are in the
course because some of the work is
happening asynchronously as well as the
synchronous but we've got a lot of folks
in none of them said that they were
focused on sustainability but when we
did a poll in one of the early classes
about how many of them had faced
resource constraints or resource issues
in their work almost seventy-five
percent said that they had so it's
exactly the kind of group that we want
the thinking here in terms of the
structure was we wanted to use the Yale
system to get as many students in as we
could we ended up across as David site
14 different schools 15 time zones and I
think that meant that's why we went to
Adobe Connect for the the online
synchronous interactions canvas is
terrific in terms of building this site
for the course and we pull this down a
little
that just scroll down yeah just too too
few fingers pc guy here there we go I'll
be happy to scroll so we built it around
these six resource systems I'll just
show you one of them so we have week one
is looking at the system as a whole and
a whole bunch of different information
week two is a case study of alcoa and
some of the issues that they're facing
in the automotive industry trying to
steal market share from steel a couple
of different things here one immense
amounts of material now on the site and
it looks much better than I could ever
make it look how did that happen our
graduate students at the environment
school need to know how to talk to and
business people so we engaged a whole
bunch of them in putting together the
material that they thought business
people needed to know we had MBA
students working with them to make sure
that it wasn't just you know green
hoopla but you know could connect to
what business people would want to hear
about and that's how we put this
together our hope is that we can use
this platform in a variety of other ways
going forward for the kinds of executive
mba programs that David and Paul anastos
and others are thinking about for the
future too broad or teaching at FES or
the broader possibly teaching in Yale
College so immense amounts of material
here the group's work pretty well
there's a people bar on the side here
and the students are breaking up into
groups and one of the reasons that they
took the class was the opportunity to
work with colleagues from other business
schools so I have to read tonight the
first materials from the students groups
on alcoa is business dilemma and I love
this because it's China Mexico India
Singapore and Ireland who work together
to put this together I have no idea if
it's any good but it's pretty cool that
they had the opportunity to work
together and this is another
component of the action learning part
here which is that this is a live case
Alcoa is trying to figure out how do
they compete with steel in the
automotive industry they just had some
big wins with a ford 150 going all
aluminum but they're sure steals going
to come back and do something else so
they want the students to help them
think outside of the box what might they
do to respond to that so we use canvas
for the home there should be an Adobe
Connect one next probably this one using
Adobe Connect as the structure for the
synchronous sessions we meet twice a
week eight thirty in the morning it's
the only time that works across the 15
time zone we can use poles for simple
questions there's a chat function down
in the lower right that i can email to
myself afterwards and as well as monitor
it during the class to ask questions in
this case we had a speaker from McKinsey
& Company so part of the cool thing here
is we have speakers from all these
different entities because the students
all want to go work for so they're
interested and then we had one of the
folks from compass rockola wanted to
come to campus and check out the new
evans hall so we couldn't use it we
connect to the classroom but so MIT
people set up this live stream so that
we have the fellow rain chefs from tight
speaking in the classroom this it goes
out by live streaming there's chat
functions back coming in so it's been a
fabulous effort from my point of view of
just sort of jumping in tremendous
support from Lucas and Sarah Doug for
Bush and others in the broadcast studio
as well as David and the IT folks at the
School of Management we do have a bunch
of different issues I probably didn't
anticipate the number of moving parts
and managing the moving parts as a
challenge each of our guest speakers is
tremendous for the students but has to
test out Adobe Connect today we found
out that GE computers don't get through
where the Adobe Connect doesn't get
through the GE computers firewall right
there
deal with lasts for a presentation next
time we're still trying to figure out
the participation grade how do we do
this we can gather lots of day doctors
on when people signed in and signed out
we can put the chat how do we analyze
that data efficiently is really tricky
we have lots of issues around holidays
the chinese new year is coming up
different people have different spring
breaks and things and trying to sort of
encourage them to be treat their group
mates with respect as they go on their
holidays is tricky and adapt academic
integrity is a challenge the TAS have
written most of the text on the canvas
website so they know what's theirs so
when people cut and paste that text into
the first assignment they kind of
recognize it but we need to have more
conversations about how one sites and
works those materials but you know I
think the opportunity to connect lots of
folks across the target schools is
working out so far really well I love
the opportunity extremely pleased with
the support we've gotten from Lucas's
team broadcasts to do som fps and others
and may be worth pointing out private
how many in addition to the ELL students
were involved in creating at how many
Yale students actually signed up for the
course in the end if you include well
the answer is smaller than you think
okay mostly because we told people they
couldn't take it I say so we ended we
started with about 12 because we wanted
to maximize the spots for four people
from other schools and also this is an
mba class right so for FES students or
for undergrads or for visitors to come
in sort of we thought this first time
what's focus on the mba students correct
so that's what we did but that's why i
say in the future you know personally i
think this is a great platform for doing
stuff at the college i want to die like
it is it well is that the final number
or that file number is about 10 yes yes
the reason why i wanted to mention
because there's so much focus and rats
presentation on China and India and
other places very Yale students who are
taking this course for credit and of
course you might say well you know they
have straight access to brads what are
they getting out at what they're getting
out of it is to work with people all
around the world and get their
perspectives so we think that you know
even for students were a local in each
of these places it's a very different
learning experience it with an efficient
we also had nine students doing an
independent project in the fall to
prepare the class lots of opportunities
for students so lots of opportunity